طالب متظاهرون في العاصمه الالمانيه برلين
بوقف فوري للاباده الجماعيه التي تقوم بها
قوات الاحتلال في غزه وندد المتظاهرون
بدعم المانيا الرسمي غير المشروط للحكومه
الاسرائيليه وكانت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه طالبت في وقت سابق بهدنيه في
غزه واحترام اسرائيل للقرارات الاخيره
لمحكمه العدل
الدوليه ينضم الينا من برلين مراس الجز
ايمن الزبير ايمن نتابع معك هذه التظاهر
من حيث الفئات العمريه المشاركه وان عدد
من يشاركون فيها بالمقارنه مع تظاهرات
السابقه عمه برلين
[موسيقى]
ايضا نعم تستمر هذه المسيره وقبل قليل تم
الاعلان عن عدد المشاركين الذي فاق حسب
المنظمين 100 الا مش ورغم التضيق ورغم
الخروج بشكل اسبوعي في برلين يستمر الدعم
الكبير لهذه المظاهرات
وتتكرر الشعارات المطالبه بوقف فوري
لاطلاق النار صراحه هناك استياء كبير من
المواقف الحكوميه الالمانيه لان معظم
الشعب الالماني يعارض هذه الحرب ولكن
يتهمون الحكومه ال بالتواطؤ مع السياسات
الاسرائيليه ويريدون ان يصل صداهم الى
القرارات التي تتخذها الحكومه الالمانيه
خاصه بعد القرارات الاخيره التي اتخذتها
محكمه العدل الدوليه يطالبون بوقف تصدير
الاسلحه الى اسرائيل لتفادي المشاركه في
ما يصفونها
بالعباده الجماعيه طبعا في الساعات
الاخيره كان هناك تغير ان صح التعبير تغير
طفيف في الموقف الرسمي الالماني وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه انالينا بيربوك طالبت
بهدنيه انسانيه لادخال المساعدات ولكن
للاشاره الحكومه الالمانيه الى حدود
الساعه ما زالت تعارض وقف نهائي لاطلاق
النار في غزه وهذا يثير كما اشرت غضب
المواطنين الذين يشاركون في هذه
المظاهرات وفي مظاهرات اخرى في المدن
الالمانيه كل اسبوع تقريبا يخرج الالاف من
المتظاهرين في برلين ولكن هناك ايضا
مظاهرات حاشده في مدن المانيه اخرى هؤلاء
يقولون انهم لن يتوقفوا عن التظاهر الى
حين تحقيق المطلب الرئيسي وهو اطلاق او
وقف فوري
لاطلاق النار اذا هذه هي الاجواء احيانا
الشرطه الالمانيه توقف بعض المتظاهرين لان
هناك قيود تفرضها السلطات الالمانيه على
المتظاهرين يمنع رفع بعض الشعارات
وبالتالي يكون هناك نوع من الاحتكاك مع
المتظاهرين كما تشاهدون الان شكرا لك ايمن
الزبير مراسل الجزيره من
برلين